start acting like your pants are on fire
don't act like you have another hour to
waste because you don't I don't care if
you're 25 or 55 the best time to plant a
tree was 20 years ago the second best
time is like right now today and get
fanatical about what does it actually
take to create enough value in the world
to be fairly compensated with what feels
like a lot of money so what is enough
what should our targets be if a million
dollars being a millionaire isn't the
goal anymore 10 million is the new
million we sort of need to add a zero to
our general thinking about money right
now depending on where you live
depending on your quality of life I need
to find somebody that embodies this this
system this construct this broken
educational model and like go punch him
in the face right now to feel better
ladies and gentlemen believe Nation I am
super excited to have a special guest
first time on the channel I think Mr
Jeff Lerner how you doing man
I am so excited I'm doing very well and
I'm even a little bit better now that
I'm here with you I love it so Jeff went
from being a jazz musician The Pianist
professional for a whole bunch of years
uh failing as an entrepreneur I think he
had 10 businesses that ended up leading
them to half a million dollars in debt
or something like that to now uh selling
over 100 million dollars online training
six figures in entrepreneurs to help
them grow and build their businesses and
he just launched a new book called
unlock your potential and I'm excited to
dive in with you man well thank you I I
appreciate uh that bio and that intro
and I'm so grateful to be here and and
excited to talk about the book or
anywhere that the conversation leads us
well you don't really hold any punches
of the book you basically Dive Right In
and you say hey a million dollars is not
even nearly enough
yeah so a lot of people like that's
their goal I was like I want to be a
millionaire and here's Jeff saying dude
a million that's not enough yeah so the
term millionaire was coined was for
first used
uh at least in written form that they
can track by Thomas Jefferson in the
1780s and at the time it referenced much
as it does today a wealthy person with a
lot of money but I think we could all
agree that what constituted a wealthy
like a notably wealthy person in 1780 is
dramatically different than today and so
the term given its age and given you
know this concept of inflation and you
know time value decay of of fiat
currency all the stuff we're hearing
about in the news right now I think that
term became passe quite a while ago at
least in the way that we use it so so
what is enough what what should our
targets be if a million dollars being a
millionaire isn't the goal anymore well
uh in my book uh there was a I can't
remember it's it's a section of a
chapter it's not an actual chapter
heading um but it's a section and it
says 10 million is the new million
obviously it's it's relative it depends
where you live uh you live in Toronto I
believe so I would say I don't know 10
million is like maybe a decent start out
there but uh and also in all seriousness
I really do think that we we sort of
need to add a zero to our general
thinking about money right now
um depending on where you live depending
on your quality of life but what was
interesting and and this this validated
the importance of this way of talking
and thinking is that when I when I
published the initial draft of the book
or I say published it wasn't published
yet but we circulated it with some beta
readers and I actually mentioned this in
the book
that line 10 million is the new million
I just got
excoriated with the beta reader feedback
people were just incensed this guy is
out of touch this guy is tone deaf this
guy doesn't understand basic math I mean
people were just really offended that I
dared to suggest that a number that is
so seemingly Out Of Reach to people
constitutes basic Financial Security in
the modern world but at the same time
I'm like uh yeah that's kind of the
whole point of the book is that our
traditional thinking and our traditional
education around not just money but
really life goals in general is so like
woefully insufficient and frankly kind
of lame in the modern world and it's
like no wonder we're consistently
getting less happy as a society because
I think I think there's this Divergence
happening where like our potential
quality of life is increasing and we're
sensing that but our actual quality of
life if anything is decreasing whether
on an on an absolute or relative basis
and that you know we're getting
increasingly aware of how good our lives
aren't
because we've been doing what we were
told and it wasn't very good advice so
you know people can throw their punches
but I stand by it
how do you get people over that belief
hurdle right so for people who are
already thinking a million dollars is I
don't know how I become a millionaire
that's on my bucket list one day and now
here's Jeff saying that's not nearly
enough if you think about the the
pianists of the world and the
entrepreneurs of the world and people in
nine to five jobs of the world like how
do you how do you get them from that
that huge Chasm of belief that you can
make 10 million dollars and and it's
easy I won't say it's easy
um I will but I will say it's imminently
doable
um and it gets a lot easier if you'll be
very selective about who you take advice
from and what lines of conventional
thought you you subscribe to and what
which ones you reject which I would
argue should be most of them and it's
funny that we're having this
conversation uh it's kind of coming full
circle you know obviously you and I met
it's been probably close to two years
when you came on my show and I remember
in that conversation
um when we were talking about your your
belief movement right and and trying to
reach people who again may be a little
bit disenfranchised May a little be a
little bit jaded and it's almost we
almost had the same conversation two
years ago right like how do you get the
person who sort of has like a little and
this isn't a pejorative statement but
they have like call it a little lower
vibration because maybe they've just
been screwed before they've had a hard
life and they don't have this innate
optimism and really high level of trust
about these amazing possibilities for
their life and so it's like it's a
little more of a stretch perhaps for
some people than maybe you or me to even
believe that like
you know if I do well at work I could
get promoted or you know good things are
even in my future whatsoever like it's
everybody's at a different level but one
thing I think we have to recognize
you know the Buddhists nailed it man the
ability to take an impartial view of our
own life
is a prerequisite for basic sanity and
high function meaning and and the really
hard thing about operationalizing what I
just said is it doesn't matter how
traumatized you are it doesn't matter
how cynical you are it doesn't matter
how crappy your life experience has been
whatever's true is equally true
regardless of your perspective
and so when I get into basic economics
or I get into the way the world works or
you know a lot of people will
subjectivize things that I say and and
kind of say well like somehow it's less
true for them based on their subjective
experience of the world but I think the
starting point of like really Shifting
the trajectory of our life is developing
that impartiality about our life where
like we're no longer
subjectively filtering and and being
biased toward our own negatively
reinforced experience up to that point
right so I'm saying that I'm being kind
of long-winded with this Preamble here
of like if somebody's about to hear what
I'm about to say I'm encouraging them to
really like sanitize the filter through
which they're hearing it right and
remove what they learn from their
parents what they learn from their
grandparents like none of us have
experienced a large enough you know
subset of all the the potential data or
experience in the world to have any real
scientifically valid basis for our
beliefs or our opinions about what's out
there and what's likely and what's
possible and what's probable right like
you know out of eight billion people in
the world I maybe know like 500 you know
so it's completely ridiculous for me to
in science and statistics if we said
okay take a sample group of 500 and use
that to derive conclusions about 8
billion they would go no your sample
size is too small so for me to say well
I know people because I know 500 of them
is it's statistically invalid and yet
all of us are walking around believing
that we know how the world works because
of what we've experienced in it even
though our sample set was so tiny right
so again I'm enrolling people into this
idea of like be willing to forget what
you think you know because you don't
actually have enough data unless you're
like Peter Thiel at palantir sitting on
this like big mountain of Big Data like
we none of us have enough data to really
be that certain of anything and so you
know that's why academic literature as
much as it's like daunting and and and
sort of like dull for a lot of people
it's actually the place to go to really
figure out how the world works because
it's it's like
scientifically valid in terms of their
methodologies for drawing their
conclusions so if you actually do that
if you look at economics if you look at
finances you look at our currency you
look at the the macro forces in the
world
I'm not unreasonable to to say that 10
million or and maybe it's five or maybe
it's 12 maybe it's eight if you live in
San Francisco maybe it's 18. if you live
in Central Kansas maybe it's four but
whatever it is it's a lot more than
you've probably been told and you just
you just work the math equation
backwards right and say okay you know
first of all I mean gosh sorry Evan I
know I'm giving like a pretty Meandering
answer to your business keep going I
like it but it's like it's like there's
it's really hard you know we're going to
be here together for maybe 45 or 60
minutes and we're going to try to like
unwind
120 years of cultural conditioning based
on an education system that was like
funded by John D Rockefeller In 1902
when he said I don't want thinkers I
want workers
and then wrote a check to start the
general education board which became the
Department of Education which funded
this and ultimately the Rockefeller
Foundation put up the first 180 million
dollars of what became the federal 20th
century school system and like here we
are going I wonder why we're producing
workers not thinkers who who not only
don't finish Rich they basically tend to
finish poor the vast majority over 90 of
people can't retire at 65. like the idea
that the retirement age is 65
is absurd if you go well at what age do
people actually retire because it's less
than 10 percent that even can at this
point and it's because
500 000 or a million you know the the
traditional retirement the financial
services industry is telling people okay
in order to retire you need 12 times the
highest level of W-2 wage which that's
the US you know I think it's called
something different in Canada but you
need 12 times the wage the highest level
of earnings that you achieved in your
career and people are going okay I make
70 grand a year that means I need 840
Grand to retire and then they're they're
they're 55 or 60 years old and they're
like well geez my 401k only has like 120
Grand in it and I'm probably not going
to save 700 000 in the next five years
so yeah I mean this is the average per
this is the average
reasonably successfully employed person
I mean it gets worse as you go down the
socio-economic ladder and so I I think
you have to be willing to like roll back
the tape of your learning way before
where most people are willing to like
most people aren't willing to say okay
virtually everything I've been told
since I was like three years old about
money and about life is completely
irrelevant in 2022 like that's just too
existentially terrifying for most people
and that's why I got so much hate about
that section of my book and and and the
book in general I've had people leave
negative reviews that are like I don't
like what he says about education and
I'm like okay subjectively you don't
like it but do you believe it it's true
or false because that's actually the
only valid opinion to have like and and
you know so anyway to the average person
to finally get to answering your
question what do I say to the average
person and I say average I don't believe
there's such a thing as an average
person but we can talk about medians in
terms of like demographics and you know
statistics to that person
I would say first of all start acting
like your pants are on fire like don't
don't act like you have another hour to
waste because you don't and I don't care
if you're 25 or 55 the best time to
plant a tree was 20 years ago the second
best time is like right now today and
get fanatical about what does it
actually take to create enough value in
the world to be fairly compensated with
what feels like a lot of money and I
think I think that's the fundamental
shift is that people are going how do I
go get a lot of money instead of how do
I go create a lot of value
and if you go create a lot of value
inevitably you will get a lot of money
because value is the aggregate
subjective opinion of what the rest of
the world thinks what you're doing is
worth
but if you go create a lot of value and
you shift your perspective to that there
is
then you only have to ask two questions
like one is what are the most valuable
things I can do in the world
and then the other is like okay what
what problems could I go solve that
would have value the solutions may not
exist but if I go solve them that will
be very valuable right and so you can do
one or two things if you're if you're a
creative Innovative entrepreneurial sort
you go okay I'm gonna go solve a big
problem and if you're not you go okay
I'm just going to move closer to the
epicenter of value in any one of the 34
million existing businesses in this
country or however many millions
wherever you live either way I mean
Grant Cardone went to Pueblo Colorado
and in 90 days built up five million
dollars of value starting from nothing
with no you know nobody even knew who he
was
because he he he asked the same question
right it's totally doable if it's doable
in Pueblo Colorado for Larry or whatever
he called himself it's doable for you
and it's doable for me and it's doable
for the average person are we going to
see Jeff Lerner take on that challenge
you know they haven't called me but I
will tell you I will I will I'm drawing
My Line in the Sand if they call the
answer is yes I am so in and the whole
and it's funny I interviewed Grant
um he had just recorded the show but it
hadn't been released yet and the whole
time I was hearing him talk about it I
was like
I I could feel myself like quivering
because I was like I want to do this so
bad you know it's like
I I yes I would I would love to do that
you could do it on there's a guy he did
it on his own did you just do it on your
own film crew and follow you around and
and you go off and do it oh I'd have to
I'd have to figure out how to get 90
days off of my responsibilities in my in
my business but maybe I don't know that
might be something to plan for but yes
if there's a will there's a way I
suppose I would watch I would tune in so
if you had to I mean this is a good
little mini case study you know if
that's you we drop Jeff Lerner we change
his name to Bill and we move him to some
you know tiny part of Kansas and now you
gotta build a five million dollar
business in whatever am I like what are
you doing let's remove the option to
just duplicate equivalently what Grant
did right because I mean he's already
solved for it once
and and his and a lot of his
fundamentals were really really solid of
like you know first of all you have to
get you have to get access to people
that think in relatively the same ways
right I mean that's one of the hardest
things about going out really creating
value in the world is like finding
finding environments that have the
precursors uh and the sort of General
mindset of value value creation and
value Focus as opposed to just a bunch
of people that are swapping time for
paychecks right which the world the
world to some degree needs that but
everybody can be more value focused in
any job in any role in any economic
situation but you know I think a lot of
it is okay how would I do what he did
how would I do it without just
duplicating what he did but again the
fundamentals that I don't think I could
ignore would be figure out where is the
value already in the environment
and and and I think the thing that
fundamentally he did that's and if he
watched that show it's different from
what everybody else did on the shows
everybody else went out and tried to
start something from nothing like I'm
gonna start a ice cream stand or I'm
gonna start an organic food store or I'm
gonna start tying people's shoelaces for
a pay for a living or like whatever
people start
he said okay I'm gonna go find a going
concern
and I'm gonna try to get a piece of The
Upside by adding value and his premise
was there are already 34 million
businesses in a country with 330 million
people like do the math on that there's
what there's nine people for every
business in the United States the U.S
needs another business like I need a
hole in the head but the re the value is
created by like or it's easier to create
value Faster by adding value to an
existing business so what I would do is
I would and again without without having
a specific Market to operate within I
would say okay what are the highest
value components of the value equation
and it's basically going to be and I
talk about this in my book Moving closer
to the the center of value Creation in
any business typically means either
dealing with sales and marketing
or the actual Financial guts of the
business right in other words if I can
go into an existing business and I can
show them how to shave a point off of a
process
that might unlock a million dollars in
upside right or if I can just help them
add incremental or marginal revenue to
something that's already operating with
a fixed Foundation then that could
unlock millions of dollars of upside
likewise very quickly and Grant went and
he he helped this what furniture store
have like their best weekend ever and he
had a deal with the guy to participate
in the upside so again I in order to
make it unique and fun to watch I
wouldn't pick a furniture store and I
might do something different but it
would still be the same thing I would be
going into existing businesses
and and helping business owners see
things through a more sort of erudite
lens of business and that would be
pulling from my experience but I'll tell
you I mean as somebody that ha let's I
have a business let me let me say from
the other side of it if somebody was in
my town
and they were like I need to make a
million dollars really fast and they
came and found me a guy that has a you
know a pretty successful business
I would you know knowing what I know
anything you can do to make me more
operationally efficient or help me
acquire more customers at scale or help
me acquire get customers to come back
and purchase again or help me justify a
meaningful price increase I mean those
are the you know Jay Abraham told us the
only three ways to make more money in a
business are either acquire more
customers get the customers you have to
buy more frequently or be able to
justifiably raise your prices right so I
would probably
hone in my radar to scan my environment
for opportunities to do one of those
three things
for any business I could tap into that
seem to have potential and and try to
negotiate a piece of the upsell I love
it if you look at that show I think it's
really divided into two parts the first
part is just survival it's like where am
I going to sleep tonight one guy
sleeping in this car in season one and
then Grant's like going to a motorhome
company and asking if you can sleep in
the motor home and it's just about
surviving and how I'm gonna eat and get
to the next step and then it becomes
about how do we actually grow and that's
almost uh
skipped over like what you just said and
broke down and Grant's strategy was
never really discussed on the show no
which is which is ridiculous because
it's the actual it's the most important
thing to come out of the show and
discover felt like oh this won't connect
with our audience because exactly what
we're talking about most people aren't
coming into watching a show like that
you know pre-wired for this kind of a
conversation because they're a product
of a system that doesn't really want to
talk about these things
um but you know this stuff again it may
sound
complicated but I think that you know
networking like Windows computers
is an inordinately more complicated than
what I just described and yet there's
hundreds of thousands of people
graduating with Microsoft certifications
to do that
it's just we just don't money is so
emotionally charged like we lit most
people have like 50 50 fewer IQ points
to like talk about it with you know
because the emotions get they get
flooded and they revert to training that
predates their intellect I mean we were
learning lessons about money before we
even had words for things
babies are like watching their parents
fight about the price of things and all
they're seeing is like item wallet
negative energy
you know and they don't even have words
to process it and so you know there's
just a lot of unlearning there's a lot
more unlearning than learning that's
required to solve this problem
so you talked about where do you get
your data from the systems that have
been set up the environment that we're
in I mean it's why I'm passionate about
creating YouTube videos you've got a
great Channel you have your own content
you interview awesome people you've got
your book now unlock your potential
what I found is people will watch a
video like this you'll read the book and
they'll have these little hits and
moments of yeah that's right I should do
this but then we fall back down because
we're still in our environment with our
family and parents and who we grew up
with and the negative mindset so how do
we how do we turn those like blips of
inspiration into a consistent flow of
action
yeah I mean I think that and and you
know I think people that know me have a
tendency to you to describe me as being
a little bit extreme you know I get up
really early and I'm I'm pretty ascetic
in some of my habits and I maintain a
really really tight circle of people and
I'm very guarded about what I allow
myself to be influenced by and you know
I'm very I'm very insistent on having
like producer relationships with media
not consumer relationships with media
because I just I you know it's like your
diet you just I mean you know the word
diet by the way if you look up the word
it just means whatever you do daily
like it comes from the German word for
Greek word dietas is day right daily
um and so I just I'm really really
strict about my diet my intellectual
emotional psychological spiritual and
literal diet of what I consume and I
think you have to be you know it's like
to realize that what is really called
for is detox
like most people just need to detox from
the world in which they exist
and you know detox is a pretty intense
environment for 90 days they don't even
let you have a cell phone or what I
don't know I haven't not actually been
thankfully but from what I hear it's
pretty intense that's why most people
leave in the first few days right that
you don't have a cell phone you're not
allowed to talk to your old friends they
don't let you see your family for 30
days or 60 days or whatever I don't know
all everything I know about rehab I know
from the show intervention but like you
create this artificially sterile pretty
intense focused environment for yourself
just so you can start to get momentum in
the absence of the old ways I think you
develop a relationship with yourself
that either either starts to support
those types of Life Choices and
behaviors or just consistently
reinforces that that's too hard that's
too uncommon that's too unlike the
people that I tend to be reinforced by
and the people that around me so I'm not
going to do it but you know how you do
one thing is how you do everything and
so for me it's like I'm constantly
trying to keep the the self-discipline
muscle in shape but it's this this
really pernicious battle because it's
not discipline like go to the gym and
lift weights it's the discipline of
saying no and training your instinct
about what should be said no to before
it's obvious that it's even bad for you
right and so it's kind of like like I
remember reading this book once about
marriage
and it was like
and it taught this method called like
bouncing your eyes and it's like if
you're a married man and you see a
pretty woman that's not your wife bounce
your eyes don't even gaze don't even
linger for three seconds because that's
the very top of a slippery slope that
you know 999 times out of a thousand
probably doesn't end in true infidelity
but it's like why keep playing this
little game that you know is is
fundamentally unhealthy so just build
the discipline to bounce your damn eyes
the second it's even in your world and
and what I try to do is build that same
level of discipline not just with like a
pretty woman that might tempt me to
think an Unfaithful thought but also
like a crappy food like a fast food
restaurant Just Bounce my damn eyes
don't even allow my stomach Grumble to
be mentally associated with the golden
arches or whatever and and bounce my
eyes from
stupid tick tocks and even on YouTube
it's like I if I see an Evan Carmichael
video and I see a video next to you that
I mean I like to think I've trained
YouTube to only serve me up nourishing
content but like sometimes I see stuff
and I have this like visceral reaction
and people like why are you so intense
and it's like because I know what that
leads to
and at the end of the day what it leads
to is just lost potential it leads to
opportunity cost it leads to like
deathbed regret and and I think at some
level you just have to get kind of more
intense about all of it if you want to
save yourself from any of it
one to your point if it's never been
easier to become wealthy that's how you
basically open the book yeah unlock your
potential everybody you want to go pick
it up uh if if you're meeting Jeff for
the first time you know 50 years ago
you'd never meet Jeff you'd never know
who he was there's no content that's
being created access to people who have
the wisdom was was locked away but now
you got guys like Jeff who are making
content right like if you love Jeff
guess what he's got his own YouTube
channel with tons of great content there
he's got his own book that just came out
he's got his own Instagram account that
you can go follow he's he's about to go
90 days in Kansas City to build a
million dollar business from zero right
right follow the journey right like
access to your mentors has now it's
never been easier so we still might be
growing up in the same environment as
everybody else who your parents did but
now you actually have a choice to make a
conscious change or for your
grandparents it would be a lot more
difficult because they didn't have the
internet and people like Jeff Lerner
were not creating content online
yeah and it's all there again but but
you got to create the space for it I
mean life is like this world we live in
is like water it fills all available
space any space you give the world today
it will fill with you know pablum and
nonsense and gibberish and meaningless
content that's you know basically like
it's you know if you go back I remember
I mean I think I was wired for this in
high school I I stopped going to class
because I just had no
I felt no relationship with the teachers
or the drivel that they were feeding me
again I I just I mean I was 16 or 15 I
didn't have like I didn't know the
history and I didn't have the language
for it but that idea that we're creating
workers not thinkers was just so obvious
to me and so I started skipping class
and going to the library and I remember
reading you know Brave New World by
Aldous Huxley and and I read 1984 by
George Orwell and I read Fahrenheit 451
by Ray Bradbury and I read the pretty
much the entire collected works of Ein
Rand you know Fountainhead Alice drugs
Anthem we the living you name it and
they're all these like dystopian books
about okay for society to function in a
in a you know overpopulated sort of
hypersaturated future
the fundamental requirement of the
people that run Society is to
to essentially drug the people in Brave
New World they called it Soma There's an
actual drug called soma now and and it's
like
I just think when we start to see the
world for what it is you know I get why
people don't want to do it like you you
end up kind of agitated and a little
pissed off but you also get to walk
around enjoy every day because you're in
the world but not of it and you know
that you're not sacrificing the vast
majority of your own life potential
for for you know
for stalling or postponing some horrible
realization that you're gonna have 10
minutes before you die that you could
have Woulda should have done all this
stuff and you didn't do it because you
bought into all these narratives I I
realized I probably sound like a tin hat
nut job right now and that's not my
intent it's just
when Society is telling you
to to borrow a hundred thousand dollars
to put yourself in an average of 22
years of debt to get a college degree
in a world where 50 of 25 year olds
still work at home and 54 of college
grads either don't have jobs or have
jobs that didn't require a college
degree
and as quickly as possible they're
trying to roll you into a 30-year
mortgage and I don't really want to talk
that much about my whole mortgage world
view because that that people get really
triggered about that and then it's all
on the basis of like this slow drip of
savings to build up some arbitrary
balance sheet number that supposedly
allows us to retire someday even though
you don't buy groceries from your
balance sheet you buy groceries from
your cash flow and retirement planning
is very is is almost never talking about
how to actually build up cash flow in
this world like we don't run our
personal finances the way any
intelligent business runs their business
finances like if you're a business and
you have seven million dollars in the
bank and no cash flow then like you're
out of business or you're or you're
draining your account and yet people
consider that to be the model for
retirement right like the conversation
is just so like broken
I don't know I I don't know you know my
book is meant to be like this 350 page
red pill that if you'll just read the
thing you'll never see the world the
same way again because you can't untake
the red pill but uh you know it's
terrifying to do and the other thing
it's terrifying when you're still in the
vacuum of misinformation that doesn't
have an answer
but like you have to take the leap of
faith faith is the the substance of what
is hoped for the certainty of what is
not seen the answer is out there but you
will not find the answer because you
will not seek the answer until you
accept the question but in order to
accept the question you have to be
emotionally mature enough to deal with
the existential Terror that comes from
realizing that even asking the question
is a rejection of 99 of what you've been
told your whole life right and that's
why that's why I say like all
professional development is really
personal development
it's about developing psychological
Clarity emotional maturity ultimately
sanity you know Scott Peck said uh
sanity is a willingness to to accept
reality as it is regardless of the
consequences
and I think that we live in an insane
world because the truth has consequences
that most people don't want to deal with
and one of those consequences is that
the traditional path is not going to
result in you having nearly enough money
to finish well
how do you go from reading all these
dystopian books and big brother and
we're being drugged to then being the
guy who wants to change all of it and
writes a book called unlock your
potential instead of being buried by it
uh because and oh this this is it and
I'll say as somebody who's married with
four kids I realize the sensitivity
around what I'm about to say
you have to start to I think for most
people there's a there's a shift
required in their relationship with
money and it's mostly an emotional shift
right it's like you you just kind of
have to emotionally get over the bad
relationship that you're in right we all
know people that stay in bad
relationships we never talk about it but
most people are stuck in a bad
relationship with money and you know
they're codependent basically right and
and so yeah you have to be willing to do
that and the I think the reason why my
arc was different is because at an early
age
I just decided money really wasn't the
most important thing now you could say
well sure you had the luxury to do that
you were uh you were a teenager you
didn't have all these responsibilities
you didn't have all these commitments
but
I'll say this you know there have been
multiple times since I have been married
since I've had children when I I had a
conversation with my wife or that was
the effectively listen in order for me
to be true to myself I have to continue
to make decisions that the archetypal
American Family construct would would
say are irresponsible in other words
because of what I believe about our
future which is me going and getting and
again there have been two critical
junctures in my marriage when I was
responsible for supporting kids as the
breadwinner when I had to have
conversations where I was like I am
never going to get a job I am not going
to trade my time for money even though
that could be a hundred thousand dollars
a year 200 000 a year whatever like I
could I could go you know circulate
resumes right now and get a great job
and of course I wouldn't think about but
there were times when that might have
been a pseudological option for me and I
had to say to my wife and children even
though it means that if I'm wrong or I'm
or or I'm unlucky or I just make a
mistake we could lose our house we could
have to downsize we could have to make
sacrifices I'm not willing to trade
our potent the potential of our future
for illusory security that ultimately
leads to a far worse future in both
absolute terms and on a weighted
probability basis in other words taking
a 50 chance of making 50 million dollars
20 years from now is far better than
having a 99 chance
of never having enough money
right it's it's return on risk it's Jeff
Bezos talks about this all the time
right a 50 chance at 50 million dollars
20 years from now is is equal to
whatever the net present value of 0.5
times 50 million is which is 25 million
discounted back 20 years maybe that's a
a 10 million dollar value opportunity
right how depending on your discount
rate
what is the value of a 100 or a 95
certainty of getting to 65 years old and
only having 200 000 or 300 000 in the
bank in a world that I'm 43 22 years
from now 25 million is going to be the
new 10 million
so what's what's the present value
discounted value of a choice that has a
virtual certainty of giving me less than
10 of what I'm going to need to retire
at the age when I have less energy less
capacity less employability less
productivity less ability to do anything
about it right most people are betting
on certain failure because they're
scared to bet on possible possible
success
I love it yeah I mean you talked earlier
about getting your pants on fire I think
it can be hard for people to get their
pants on fire around Net Present Value
calculations and this becomes part of
the struggle
you know for you when you're half a
million dollars in debt you realize oh I
can't just get a job to get me out of
this it's not like a five thousand
dollar debt I need to radically think
different because this is a lifetime of
debt if I don't strategically change my
Approach
how can we create pants on fire when we
are maybe we're not happy but we're also
kind of comfortable
um I mean you know I will say if I had
the answer to that I would be selling
six pack out six pack AB programs I'd be
selling diet plans I'd be selling gym
equipment I'd be selling you know
relationship advice and fair I mean like
most of our problems in the health
wealth and relationship categories which
are the you know sort of the the the
three legs of the stool of quality of
life uh most of them basically involve
changing our relationship with time you
know I talk about breaking up with your
relationship with money oh my gosh I
gotta I gotta ditch one unhealthy
relationship well there's a whole other
one which is our relationship with time
you know and I have an approach that I I
constantly come back to that I call
horizonalization where I have to really
assess the irrational value that I'm
placing on the present relative to
different points in the future you know
the present and the future are the same
thing at different times
so to arbitrarily choose a moment of
comfort against a a future of years of
pain
is is actually a form of insanity
but like we're constantly battling our
own wiring right like our default wiring
is just like stay alive now don't die
now have enough food now find a cave to
get out of the rain now so that we can
at least get our kids to the point where
our DNA can perpetuate even if you know
the saber-toothed tiger bites my head
off right like we have all this
pre-wiring that we come with that has
become so incompatible with the world
today that I again this is where I think
you have to first of all nobody has the
willpower to like
to like change their relationship with
all this information that they're
constantly being inundated with while
they're being inundated with it right if
that's like saying I want to have the
willpower to eat pizza and McDonald's
cheeseburgers and yet develop a six-pack
dunk a basketball and run a 4 4 40. I'm
gonna be so strong-willed that even
though I'm feeding myself crap my body
will still perform as if I'm training
hard like there's a it's Way Beyond
willpower right it's literally what are
you feeding yourself
and and again what we can't we can't we
can't utilize space that we haven't
created so my my advice I mean if
somebody's listening this whole
interview like geez this guy talks a lot
he's kind of all over the place and I
don't even know I what what am I
supposed to take away from that this is
what I would say is
cut out
anything in your life that isn't leading
you
to the to to the life that you want
and if you do an honest assessment of
your life and you say is my job leading
me to the life that I want and and I
mean the life that you wanted back when
you still allowed yourself to dream like
some of us have just gone okay the only
way I can tolerate the gap between my
present State and my desired state is to
just learn to desire a lot less right
give yourself permission to desire a
real quality of life the life of your
dreams you know learn to dream again
that's a whole conversation right and
once you do that then audit your life
you have 168 hours a week
how many of them are actually being
spent with with people with ideas with
businesses with skills development with
knowledge acquisition how many of those
168 hours a week are actually being
spent with things they could reasonably
lead you to the life that you want for
most people it's literally zero and I
don't say that because I'm like up on
high telling people how it is I say that
because I run an online education
platform an entrepreneurial education
platform that's enrolled 271
000 students in the last four years and
we do these analyzes we do these audits
I have data from our coaches I have data
from our concierges I have data from our
student surveys and the reality is that
in the absence of great intention
and and major changes changes such that
most of the people in your life will
start to look at you different and
actually think that something has gone
wrong when really it's because you're
finally making things go right I mean
like like you can't make these changes
is in secret like people will notice and
and that's why like I think that
worrying about the Judgment of others is
actually the single thing that locks up
most human potential because it's the
reason we don't make the changes even
when we know we should but like if
you'll actually make these changes
you know and and even if you spent
here's the thing you don't have to read
reallocate all 168 hours we still have
to sleep we still have to brush our
teeth but what if you just gave it 10.
right or or ten and a half that would be
90 minutes a day seven days a week say I
am putting barricades around 90 minutes
a day and with as an absolute law under
penalty and I like to actually find
myself I talk about this in the book
that if I break a promise to myself I
have to pay a fine to a charity so I
actually win either way but like
literally start tree if
if I told somebody that if they do not
meet me at the gym at four o'clock
tomorrow morning then there will be a
hundred thousand dollar Levy placed on
them by their state governments and you
know most of their assets will be seized
they'd be at the gym at four in the
morning right like but nobody we as
we've established we don't live in a
world that's going to punish you for not
doing the right thing we actually we
just live in a world that's gonna reward
you for doing the wrong thing but isn't
that actually kind of the same thing
right so you just got to flip the game
and say I'm gonna punish myself for not
doing the right thing now the word
punish sounds punitive same root like
penal like we've got all these dis
associations with it call it a
consequence call it a natural outcome
right but like start enforcing
boundaries on yourself and and what even
if it's nine minutes a day
you know what am I doing that's actually
moving me towards the life that I want
or that I would have wanted back when I
gave myself permission and the ability
to drink you mentioned waking up super
early and being extra disciplined what
are some of the maybe harder to connect
to or weirder habits that Jeff Lerner
does on a daily basis to stay consistent
so actually this is go this is going on
video right
[Laughter]
probably
yeah yeah
I guess we'll see where this goes I'm
not about to like disrobe or anything
but like this is my
this is my schedule on my phone right
and I don't know how visible that is but
it starts at 3am I'm on I'm on a 3 A.M
clock right now I have wake up slash
audio book from three to four which
means why I wake up one of the first
things I do is pop my airpods in and I
start listening to an audiobook I'm
listening to a book on leadership right
now from four to five I have Mobility
training I'm 43 I'm older than I used to
be and then I ever really wanted to be
so I'm trying to recapture the
pliability of my youth so I've been
doing an hour a day of Mobility then I
have 30 minutes of weight then I have 30
minutes of showering and changing then I
have an hour of piano practice here in
my office then I have an hour of what's
called Jada Stella time which is time
with my daughters and so for me by 8 am
you know I talk about
dedicating time that's moving you toward
the life that you want by 8 am I've had
five hours up
right that's 30 five days a week that's
25 hours and the weekends are a little
different but like I spend as much time
working on myself as most people spend
working for somebody else
right and you know now did I start there
no I used to be broke I used to be like
most people I used to have to trade
every minute I could for money to to get
ahead or to live but again if people
really do an analysis of what they're
living for and what they consider to be
an essential standard like you talked
about survival right like that show was
was bifurcated between like the survival
conversation which is what plays to most
people because that's where most
people's heads are at and then like the
what are the first principles of
actually thriving and and winning at
this you know this sort of artificial
game which they didn't even really talk
about because like you said that's not
what Discovery wanted to show but like
when we think about survival
you know we tend to compare ourselves to
eight billion humans let's compare
ourselves to the hundred and I think
it's 118 billion humans
that have lived in the history of the
world and theoretically survived enough
to procreate or else we wouldn't be here
and ask ourselves like what is this
standard that I'm really insistent on in
other words what am I sacrificing in my
life because I think that a house with
fewer bedrooms would be failure
what am I sacrificing in my life because
I just don't want to have a hard
conversation with my spouse or my kids
about how based on some very obvious
like probabilities and very obvious
statistical realities of the world we
live in
the world that we've created for
ourselves is actually a shell game it's
a math equation that's never going to
resolve and so I'm going to make some
different choices but as a consequence
we not we might not be able to replace
our PlayStation this year at Christmas
or like you know what are the things
that we've decided are the floor of
survival that are laughable in the
context of what most human beings I mean
did you know that a hundred
I think it was 130 years ago I forget
the stat the stat I I heard about this
the other day 130 years ago
it was a very common thing for women to
lose teeth when they were pregnant
because the human body had to steal
calcium to build bones for the baby and
their teeth would fall out that was 130
years ago right women still had babies
human species still thrived and we truly
believe now that without a 3 000 square
foot house in Suburbia we are failures
and we mortgage our entire life on the
basis of what we call survival which is
really just keeping up with an idea
that's based on false premises anyways
you know again there's I haven't figured
out how to how to make this pill easier
to swallow I haven't figured out how to
see clearly
without drawing such dramatic or
disruptive conclusions I actually I wish
I wish we could I wish we could say like
oh it's just these like small tweaks you
know like like watch a little less TV
and try a little harder at work and you
know maybe maybe like two less nights a
year playing poker with your friends or
like no it doesn't work like that
honestly very very few people in this
world really get awesome lives and that
is why most people think that awesome
lives are really hard to come by but I
believe in in today's world not in the
cast system of a thousand years ago or
the medieval feudal system or all these
other systems we want to point to and go
see no no it's not fair right now today
in a capitalist World in a westernized
world in a democratic country the vast
majority of people could have almost any
life they could possibly imagine if they
were just willing to reject enough
pieces of the life that they have
currently found themselves with I
believe that to my core I love it man
and I think you're doing it like you're
waking people up with your with your
Channel your content the books your
training the courses all of it
now because we haven't triggered people
enough
give us your uh quick take on mortgages
oh geez I did I did open that that box
didn't I yeah I I and I and I do talk
about this some in the book I mean I
think that again if you're willing to
separate yourself emotionally and
neurologically from the comfort of
conventional wisdom and the comfort of
just you know confirmation bias it's
like I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna
dramatically prefer information that
confirms what I already believe and and
be skeptical or or outright reject or or
actually I think what most people do is
they just act like it doesn't exist
information that contradicts what I've
what I've gotten comfortable believing
if you're willing to do that and I again
it's not even about willpower it's about
conditioning like it's a habit you have
to get in the habit you know we are what
we repeatedly do
therefore insert you know the quote is
is Aristotle Excellence then is not a
virtue but a habit right or uh but but
you can insert Excellence you can insert
Clarity you could insert sanity you
could insert
developing an informed opinion about
30-year mortgages like you can it's it's
all based on how we habitually force
ourselves to be pure and sane and clear
in the way we process questions right
and and that willingness to divorce
ourselves from things just because we've
heard them a million times because I
will say if you're like well no I still
am not willing to do that consider the
sources if the vast majority of people
that you've gotten your information
throughout life do not actually have the
life that you want it's reasonable to
suggest that thinking the way they do
will get you what they got which you
just said isn't the life you want right
so maybe that makes it easier but but in
any case
um mortgages I believe are generally bad
economics
because
again people talk about
your house being the biggest asset that
you'll have in your life look I I
consider assets
I don't consider an asset the value of
an asset to be what somebody will pay me
for something now I consider the value
of an asset to be
the cash flow that it per The Net
Present Value again you're like well
that's that's a that's a confusing term
for a lot of people why the hell do so
many people know what the periodic table
of elements is why do so many people
know what cellular meiosis is why do so
many people know that you know Andrew
Johnson had a duel because they learned
it in school
and the reason they don't know what Net
Present Value is is because again to my
point they didn't teach us in school
like we know what those other things are
they're not inherently more complicated
than the concept of Net Present Value
Net Present Value just means what is
money in the future where's today right
and so when I look at at an asset value
I say I look at it as cash flow either
what is it going to save me that's
positive cash flow in the sense of I'm
not going to have to spend it or what is
it going to earn me that's positive cash
flow in the sense of of it's actually
going to come into my personal economy
right and when you look at the value of
a house over the life time that you live
in it and you go look at all the money I
dumped into it was that really the best
utilization of those funds no I think
the net equation should be I'm going to
live
at whatever my minimum required standard
of living is so that I can at least get
up in the morning and go do the work
that I need to do and I'm going to do it
as cheaply as possible with as few
long-term obligations and restrictions
as possible which you know people don't
typically factor in the long-term cost
of being stuck in one place of being
illiquid of not being able to move
because depending on the market it might
take time to sell your house or having
to pay for improvements that even if you
want them you wouldn't have paid for
them if you'd been renting because it
wasn't your property that you would have
been inspired to improve like if you
really do the macro calculation of the
cost of home ownership versus the cost
of just renting and living as cheap as
possible and then taking every possible
bit of surplus in that equation and
using it to create cash flow
over the same 30 years and remember
during that 30 years you represent cash
flow for the lender
right that's if mortgages mortgages were
that good a deal for you
the lenders wouldn't be so eager to give
them to you right you know there's a
buyer and a seller in every equation and
if you're buying somebody else is
selling and and you know like who's
smarter you or the banks right and so
again I think if you really do the math
I mean the short answer your question
sorry I should have just answered with
one word math
math but it's emotionless math you have
to get over all the emotions before you
do the math
I love it well the man is Jeff Lerner
the book is called unlock your potential
we'll link it up down in his description
below go check it out Jeff man thanks
for coming on board oh this has been
great Evan I'm looking at myself in the
mirror and I'm like I'm like I don't
know if I just feel comfortable with you
because we're like friends we you know
kind of work in the same circles but
like I really I really like turned that
up my forehead's all red I feel flushed
I feel hot like is there do you have
like a boxing gym I can go to right now
like I want to like
I need to find somebody that embodies
this this system this construct this
broken educational model and like go
punch him in the face right now just to
feel better but that's that's that's the
next that's the next line of products
you got the boxing bags that have bank
logos on it and and school logos on it
to beat up yeah John D Rockefeller a
bust of John D thank you Jeff thanks
Evan to see my one-on-one with Grant
Cardone talking about his billionaire
Journey check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe see you there I'll tell
everybody right now I didn't hit the
target spoiler you got kovitz yeah they
are testing me every week the first week
I test positive I'm calling home every
night on my new phone to my wife crying
like a little baby